لذلك هذا هو اختيار الطعام الذي يتم
تقديمه مباشرة بعد الإقلاع ، لقد
اخترت أن يكون لدي جميع الخيارات الثلاثة الرئيسية
حتى أتمكن من تذوق
ما هو معروض وهو سمك النهاش المشوي على شكل رأس أسد
لدينا اللحم البقري ممتلئًا و
زلابية الكركند المطبوخة على البخار في
حساء فاخر ، هذه ليست سوى الوجبة الأولى من بين العديد ،
كيف قررت ترتيب الوجبات
لأنه في العمل تكون الوجبة الأولى
بعد الإقلاع ثم يتعين علينا الانتظار
خمس ساعات قبل تقديم الوجبة التالية ،
هذا صحيح ، نعم نحن نفعل
هل لدينا 10 سنوات من الخبرة مثل هذا
روب من سنغافورة يسير إلى الوراء منذ سنوات
، ثم في نفس الوقت نحتاج إلى بعض
الإلكترون في سنغافورة سان فرانسيسكو ،
لذلك قمنا بعدد كبير من خدمات مجرفة
مختلفة على مسار الرحلة
وبعد ذلك نحن  قرروا أن معظم
الركاب بعد الصفقة الأولى سوف
يلتزمون بحوالي ستة آلاف وست ساعات
ويستيقظون باحثين عن
نوع الطعام الذي قررت أن ينجح
ونوع الطعام الذي لا يصلح ما هو
معظم الطعام  أن صوتنا يبدأ
العمل بشكل جيد جدًا ، كان الأمر مختلفًا لا
يعمل لأننا تعرضنا للإهانة ، لذلك نشير
في هذه الحالة إلينا جميعًا أن
تكافؤنا هو أننا ننظر إلى الراكب
بعمق ثم من مرور
أوباما سنحدد الأطباق و  ما
هو ملف تعريف الركاب الذي يخبرك أن
هذا العصر الحديث في هذا الوقت هو المنشور الذي يستند إلى
ما يقرب من خمسة عشر آسيويًا وخمسة عشر
وخمسين بالمائة من آسيا